the point is that anthropology exists
not to tear people apart but to bring
them together
it's not about the traditional versus
the modern it's it's about the rights of
free people everywhere
to choose the components of their lives
it's certainly not about freezing people
in time like some kind of zoological
specimen as if they're frozen in the
past it's about
asking ourselves what kind of world do
we all want to live in
how can we all find a way that all
peoples everywhere
benefit from the genius of science and
modernity
but without that engagement demanding
the death
of who they are as a people and the
reason for this is clear
it's not an issue of nostalgia romance
even human rights it's about
geopolitical stability
because culture is not trivial culture
is not superficial culture is not the
songs we sing the prayers we utter the
clothes we wear
the dances we do culture ultimately
is a body of ethical and moral values
that every culture places around each
individual within that culture
to keep at bay the barbaric heart that
history sadly teaches us
lies within all human beings it is
culture that allows us to make sense out
of sensation
find order and meaning in the universe
to do as lincoln said
in his first inaugural address to seek
the better angels
always of our nature and what happens
when culture is lost when the
constraints
of morality and ethics flounder and are
torn apart what happens is what happens
all around us
just take a look around as human beings
either through volition or coercion are
torn from constraints
and the comfort of their past as they
find themselves on the lowest rung of an
economic ladder that goes nowhere
in a sea of alienation and disaffection
out of that comes
all the points of crisis around the
world
so the fight for the integrity of
culture is not a rhetorical fight
it's a real battle and we have to fight
and people will die
it's not about the twiddling of thumbs
and i want to remind everybody that
we're in this together
no one has monopoly on suffering
but the bottom line is this we still
live
in a world of conflict and when we live
in a world
where the people in gaza are being
bombarded by the day
live in a world where a million ubers
are in chinese
prison camps and concentration camps
where the forest of the penang has been
laid waste and with it
a whole way of life morally inspired
inherently right
with an extraordinary knowledge of that
forest has been swept away in a single
generation
anthropology must re-take
the challenges of our time it has to
take on the
the the the mission of boaz and his
people we must be the
the activist warriors who stand up for
the integrity
of all peoples of all cultural
expressions of every point of one of the
human imagination to be found in all
parts of the world
and now's the time to do it a time when
the languages are being lost the forests
are being cut
the systems of life themselves
compromised it is only humanity
that can find its way out to a brighter
day